quand j'étais juste un petit enfant,
j'ai juste sauté pour vivre pour l'avenir
alors
comment puis-je vivre pour moi-même
nous avons 10 ans dans maintenant
10 ans et les morts ont toujours ce
monde
tu penses vraiment que le monde va finir
[Musique]
je sais  c'est
notre père qui a des ennuis nous devons l'aider
à mourir nous
pourrions vivre  ta sœur,
ils comptent tous sur toi
[Music]
il n'y aura peut-être rien dans ce
coin
[Music]
mais tôt ou tard il y aura
ce qui nous attend ça ne va pas être facile
mais
nous allons faire en sorte que nos vies comptent pas
parce que nous  tu es la dernière génération
parce que nous sommes au début
[Musique]
il y a un grand et beau monde qui
t'attend là-bas